you know Scotland's a weird place like
you have to dress a certain way when you
hunt there uh-huh
or at least they have a certain way they
dress like a traditional way I like that
but it's not like they don't wear camo
it's like an outfit yeah it's like an
outfit like what do they wear the world
like clothes a weird old-timey clothes I
like that I like tradition um yeah I
know you did that's why I brought it up
Bourdain went hunting in Scotland
there's a television show or anything
had to wear some crazy ass outfit right
you get suited for this outfit this
traditional hunting outfit it's pretty
cool yeah a lot of those this that's its
traditions like places like Scotland to
if I'm in cry think most of it was like
private land right I think back in the
day like that was what Robin Hood was
all about right Robin Hood was
originally supposed to be about someone
who was poaching and hunting on the
king's land because they were hungry and
so they were stealing from the rich to
feed the poor gentlemanly pursuit
hunting and shooting a tire Wow a dress
does that help you helps me be a good
hunter because I get to goof on them or
does it like does that help does that
get in the way of hunting or is that
help hunting that's not helping shit
it's kind of fresh though go back to his
boots yeah man that guy looks boots can
make them boots larger look at those
fresh boobs yeah come on I start wear
those on stage that what I get in
trouble for cultural appropriation
wearing someone's stuff if they're white
to network and now that if they're more
powerful than you than your okay like
how does that work how does that work
you can't take from how much what
percentage of Native American do you
have to have in you to wear moccasins
ooh a lot the tassel jacket how about
the leg the suede tassel jacket the like
Roger Daltrey rebels in the seventies
war I wanted one of those so bad when I
was in high school they look so cool the
Easy Rider with the fringe on it it's
all moving driving
man I want your arm out the window with
a card it's flopping yeah you're on
stage singing the ladies must have yeah
look at that
Oh Gloria come on strips of leather see
but that goes too far see how it's
because they have the Native American
thing I'm a sleeve we see this one right
here no not the other one well that
one's yeah you get so far that one if
you do that one you better kill the bear
that it use for those fucking yeah me
that's - that's ridiculous
now there's a white guy version of that
which would be okay that's a girl claims
to be a healer yeah that's what we're
that see if you wear that in Texas
you're okay oh yeah okay Daniel Boone
yeah that one that one's dark dark one
no what are you prince like that guy
will you a trapper
that's too light that looks terrible
it's terrible he's get the fringe in the
bottom so that gets you to separate us
from everybody else the curtains on the
bottom fringe like a nice curtain and a
flame a fine restaurant look at Elvis
Elvis had tassels Elvis had rainbow
tassels you could get away with it if
you're Elvis if you if you're working
for Enterprise rent-a-car maybe you know
where that yeah Elvis got away with some
wild shit who the fuck were jumpsuits
before Elvis jumpsuits it was him and
Evel Knievel oh yeah oh man look at that
Hendrix oh my god that's yeah see but
he's doing some of these playing on
guitar he's moving around he's got a
headband if he just if you're making
snow cones you know if that's not your
jacket man I wanted one when I was in
high school I wore my put that back up
put that picture bear up look at that
that look how good does it look and I
could never wear he's got friends on uh
yet what does a greenish yellow how
would you describe that color it's like
a teal like a light teal a light teal
he's got he's got bottoms the lot of
Jesus had washed bell bottoms and he's
got this cool jacket with fringes that
are literally two feet long
yeah and then a headband - and it's just
his kind of fuchsia that had
right it's kind of reddish yeah like a
light red and he's and it's on Jimi
Hendrix that's that's the thing that we
can't match when we could buy all those
items but it's still our head it's not
Jimmy Hendrix not only that it's 2019
too